Brad Chen: Good morning.
Thanks very much for joining
this session of Google IO.
My name is Brad Chen,
and I'm the Engineering Manager
of the Native Client project.
And I'm really looking forward
to telling you
a little bit about that today.
I also wanted to mention
right away
that we have other events
planned for you today.
There's a Fireside Chat
at 1:00
and office hours
for the Native Client project
at 3:00.
And a bunch of the team
members are here today.
Can you guys say hello?
We're looking forward
to answering
any questions you have
about how to use Native Client,
how to get comfortable with
the system, that sort of thing.
So...let's get on
with it then.
Let's talk a little bit about
Native Client and native code.
Now, why would anybody want
native code in a web browser
anyways?
I mean, it's been such a big
source of problems in the past.
Well, there's a number
of really basic things
that are motivating us.
Firstly, performance.
The JavaScript implementations
that are available in browsers
like Chrome nowadays
are really quite
incredibly good.
But in spite of that,
there's still about two
orders of magnitude difference
between what you can do
with JavaScript
and what you can do
with native code.
And the hardware architecture
trends actually suggest
that that gap is going to
continue to broaden.
Things like vector instructions
and threading
are just not useful features
in today's browser
for JavaScript-based systems.
And so that performance,
approximately
two orders of magnitude,
just isn't available.
So performance is really
the main thing driving us,
and you'll see some other
evidence of that
as I tell you
more about the system.
Apart from performance,
I kind of think
that people should
be able to use
any programming language
they want.
She shouldn't be obliged to only
use one particular language.
And so native code
and native compilation
makes a lot of additional
languages available.
And not only are the languages
available that you like then,
but also all the legacy code
that exists in those languages.
And we're doing a lot
to try and make it easy
to import
and use legacy code.
So...with these benefits,
you might wonder,
well, gee whiz, you know,
ActiveX and NPAPI,
you know,
Netscape and Microsoft
introduced those ten years ago,
so what's the big deal?
Well, a couple of things
you never got
with these previous systems
are portability and safety.
An ActiveX plugin
only runs on Windows,
and NPAPI plugins typically
do use the native OS interfaces,
so you can't move them
from operating system
to operating system.
Moreover,
because they have access
to those native operating
system interfaces,
they have full access
to the file system
and full access to the network.
They can do anything you want,
which is, you know,
great on the one hand,
unless you happen to be
the recipient of such a module
that wants to send junk mail
or infect your computer
with viruses.
And so, these are things
that we've made
very specific design decisions
and done a lot of work
to try and make
much more difficult.
Our goal, in terms of
portability and safety,
is to deliver a system
that gives about the same level
of portability and safety
as JavaScript,
and eventually, you know,
we'd like to even do better
than JavaScript.
So that's sort of the background
on why native code.
Now, what do we mean
by performance?
'Cause, I mean, you can write
pretty fast JavaScript nowadays.
Well, what we mean is,
literally,
we wanna be within
single digit percentages
of the best you can do
with desktop native code.
And in particular,
it means supporting
features like threads.
Modern CPUs are multicore
and also will tend to be
multithreaded,
and so we've put a lot
of effort into providing
a subset of POSIX threads
in Native Client...
also sometimes known as
"enough rope to hang yourself".
But we're also providing
abstractions
on top of the threads
to make them easier to use.
So for example,
Intel's Thread Building Blocks
builds cleanly
on top of Native Client,
and that's a kind of
higher level interface.
Another important
performance feature
which I already mentioned
briefly is vector instructions.
And we'll be showing you
an example today
of an application
that uses SSE instructions
to accelerate photo processing.
And, last but not least,
for the people who really need
the highest level of performance
available in their applications,
we make it relatively
straightforward
to use hand-coded assembler
for the small number
of people
who are actually interested
in doing that.
But for the really high end
performance-oriented things,
the computational kernels,
animation applications,
that sort of thing,
all that performance
is available
and substantially as available
as in a desktop
programming environment.
So what does this mean
for the Web?
What are the new things that we
think Native Client will enable?
Well, as an example,
by giving the CPU performance--
making it available
in web applications,
we think we can enable safer
multimedia codecs.
You'll be able to have
a multimedia codec
that's embedded
in a safe environment
instead of running
as unconstrained native code.
We'll show you some examples,
and we have other examples
in our open source project
of real-time audio and video
synthesis.
This is animation, right,
so substantially more ambitious
than just displaying a video.
We're actually
creating the video
and then showing it to you.
Another thing
that's really important
in a lot of modern user
interfaces and games
is physics simulations.
You actually need to have
Newtonian physics
with object colliding
into each other
and responding
in realistic ways.
And again, in our Quake demo,
which is available
in our open source release,
you can see an example of that.
You know, just briefly
going through the list,
audio and video analysis
and recognition,
things like face recognition
we think should be possible
in browser-based applications
with, you know,
with native code.
Multimedia editors.
Eventually high-throughput
cryptography
and more flexible
than just using SSL.
You'll be able to encode
and decode the content
as you determine.
And application-specific
data compression,
which has a potential
to give you
much more dense representations
of domain-specific data
than just a generic compression
algorithm like gzip.
Together with this,
with O3D,
that is the 3-dimmensional
graphics interfaces for the Web
that Google
has recently introduced,
we think we'll be able
to enable things
like high quality games,
games that start to approach
the quality of things
that you're accustomed
to seeing on consoles,
as well as CAD applications
and a whole variety of things.
So these are the kind
of applications
that we want to be able
to enable with Native Client.
Now...so that's enough
for background.
What I want to do right now--
and what we're gonna spend
most of the time on today--
is going through some examples
of actual Native Client
applications that we've built
and show you some of
the nuts and bolts
of how things are put together.
Before showing you that,
I'm gonna go through
a series of architecture
diagrams
so you can sort of see
how the pieces--
what are the pieces
and how they work together
before we do the examples.
So suppose, for example,
you wanted to write
a little game--
Global Cooling we're gonna
call it in this case--
and it's implemented
as a web-based application.
It happens to use
a Native Client module,
so being a web-based
application,
there's gonna be
some HTML someplace.
Now, there's two models that
we're gonna talk about today
for using
Native Client modules.
One is as a plugin,
and that's what we're gonna
talk about in this example.
The other
is using web workers,
an emerging HTML standard
that you probably
heard about yesterday.
So in this case,
if you're using a plugin,
you'll commonly use
an object tag.
And there'll be
a source argument
and a number of other
arguments,
but there'll be a source
argument to the object tag
that says where is the content
that's gonna be activated
by the plugin?
When Native Client
sees the object tag
and the mime type
associated with it,
when the browser sees that,
it actives the Native Client
infrastructure
and, in particular,
a helper module
that knows how to handle
the native code
and enable it for
the web-based application.
The browser, when it sees
the source argument,
is going to download
the untrusted native code
from a website
someplace on the internet.
Now, in the case
of climate modeling,
we probably will need
some physical simulation.
So that's what most of...
the scenario's
gonna be based on.
But suppose,
just for a moment,
suppose that somebody
was trying to trick you
and get you to download and run
something dangerous, okay?
So before Native Client
is gonna enable this module,
it's going to pass it through
a security inspection,
a static analysis
of the actual machine code,
to make sure
that there are no sharp edges,
nothing dangerous.
And if it sees a module
that breaks the rules,
that does some of the things
that are explicitly
not allowed in Native Client,
that module will be rejected,
and we will refuse to run it.
And that's exactly
what will happen
for random x86 binaries
that you might choose.
Because there's
a set of instructions,
a set of constructs
in the machine code
that we simply don't allow
because they lead
to safety problems.
But if the Native Client module
in question
has been built properly
and follows all of the rules
that we've identified
for the system,
then it will pass through
the security scan.
And the next step
is to load it into a container.
That's where
it will be contained
and allowed to run safely.
We actually think
of this container
as kind of like
being in jail,
'cause there's still
a set of things
that we're not gonna allow
this native code to do.
It's still gonna be
somewhat constrained.
But now that it's activated
on your desktop
and established and running,
we can connect it
so it can communicate
freely with the browser.
And at that point,
it's gonna be able to actually
interact with the browser,
and the browser, of course,
will be able
to interact with it--
graphics, you know, events,
all that sort of thing.
So we've got our Native
Client-enabled web application.
So that's a high level model
of what's going on.
Just to be explicit
about a couple of details--
a couple of nuances
of the system--
we run the Native Client
modules
in their own address space,
and that's actually mostly
for exception isolation.
We don't need that isolation
for memory protection.
We've actually implemented that
in our sandbox.
But exception handling
is more challenging.
The operating systems don't
know how to handle exceptions
except by killing the task.
So by putting the Native Client
process module
in its own process,
we prevent the operating system
from terminating the browser.
Another thing is
the communication interface
that's indicated
with the arrows there
allows for a simple message
passed in communication.
In addition to that,
something that we've done
that's really very powerful
is we provide
a shared memory--
you can establish
shared memory regions
between the Native Client
module and the browser.
And that's essential
for doing things like graphics
that require really high
communications throughput.
The shared memory regions
also allow you
to implement things
like spinlocks
in the case that you need
really high frequency
communication.
So although you can actually
do pretty well
in terms of latency
with the message passing
interface too.
So that's the architecture
at a really high level,
and keep this in mind as we go
through the three examples.
I want to tell you
a little bit about
security of Native Client,
'cause it's a legitimate
concern for anybody
who's ever used an ActiveX
or an NPAPI control.
And it's really what we spent
most of our time on so far
in the project.
Our goal,
like I mentioned earlier,
is to make native code
at least as safe as JavaScript
and HTML
and the other things
that people, you know,
basically take for granted
in web content.
So some examples
of steps that we've taken
to make Native Client safer--
firstly, multiple internal
security reviews.
We code review all our code.
That's a standard
Google practice.
And anything that gets
presented publicly from Google
goes through a design review
and an implementation review.
The implementation review
is a really fun one.
That's one--we hire
all these scary black hat guys,
and they spend time--
they get paid for finding
bugs in our code.
So we managed to survive that.
But that wasn't enough,
actually.
We felt compelled to do more.
So we've open sourced
the system.
The system has been open sourced
since December 8th,
and we've encouraged
public critical review,
in part
by submitting papers
to prestigious
technical conferences.
We recently had a publication
in IEEE Security and Privacy,
which is a really good
security conference.
And more than that,
we held a security contest.
We actually challenged
the community
to find bugs in our system,
and we're gonna be paying
cold, hard cash
to the people who have found
the most interesting exploits.
That contest actually ran
for about two months,
ending on the 5th of May.
And just some kind of background
on what we put ourselves
through--
over 400 teams signed up
to compete in this contest,
and over 600 individuals.
Of those people, there were only
22 issues submitted
that were actually valid.
Valid in the sense that,
you know,
we agreed they were
a vulnerability of any sort.
And I provided
a little high-level profile
of the issues that we saw.
Most of them were related
to browser integration,
issues with, you know,
dealing with NPAPI
or, you know,
memory allocation and management
in that context.
There are a couple of issues
with the inner sandbox too.
That's that validator
that does the static
analysis of the program.
And to just give you
the next little detail,
I wanted to share with you
a couple of the more
interesting issues
that we saw in the contest.
You can see
the entire list of issues
if you go to the Native Client
code site.
But just kind of for
the purpose of the talk here,
one interesting bug--
the Native Client system
relies on being able to
disassemble the program
accurately
and understand
all possible control flow.
And so this first bug
was an example
where we had
a control flow analysis issue.
Now, the Native Client system
has disallowed
the x86 prefix byte
for 16-bit address computation.
Addr 16,
it's commonly called.
And that's important,
'cause that lets you do
kinds of address calculations
that let you jump
anywhere in the code,
so defeating our intention
of being able
to reliably
disassemble the program.
Well, but we missed
a case of that.
It turns out that you can
use a different prefix,
the data16 prefix,
to do
16-bit address calculations
for a certain set of jump
instructions that we neglected.
And so it happened to be
two-byte jump instructions.
So the solution
to address this problem
and prevent this arbitrary
control-flow transfer
is to disallow
the data16 instruction
for a bunch of additional
two-byte instructions
that we hadn't considered
before.
And furthermore,
we took an additional step
of un-mapping the entire
first 64 kilobytes
of the address base
of the Native Client module
so that any 16-bit address
would never be a valid address
for a control-flow transfer.
So one other quick example--
I know this
is a little bit gritty,
but just want to, you know,
make the point
of the kinds of
steps we're taking
to secure the system.
There was a stack smashing
attack vulnerability found
dealing with the eflags
direction flag.
Now, on the x86 architecture,
you probably know
there's some repeat instructions
that can be used to copy
very long strings.
And with those
mov instructions,
there's a flag
that determines
whether it copies forwards
or backwards.
Well, it turns out
there was a place
where we didn't check
those flags
before invoking system calls
of the native operating system.
And furthermore,
there was a window system call
that used a repeat movs
instruction
without checking
the direction flag first.
So the combination
of those two problems
meant that you could
actually use
the Windows stack smashing
prevention code
to do a stack smashing attack,
which is kind of ironic.
Fortunately, again, the
solution was not too difficult.
It was just a matter
of clearing the flags carefully
before every time we invoke
anybody's system calls.
So that gives you hopefully
a little bit of intuition
about the kind of tricky stuff
that is involved
if you're going to attempt
to defeat the system.
The good news,
and the thing that we're
actually very pleased about,
is although there were
a few, you know,
22 issues submitted
to the contest,
there were no real fundamental
architectural issues.
They were all basically
implementation defects,
and the kind of defects
that we had no trouble
fixing in a matter of days.
So that kind of reinforced
our belief
that it's possible
to implement a system
that achieves a substantial
level of safety.
Okay.
So before we dive into
the details of the examples,
I wanted to tell you
a little bit about
where the project is today
and where we're going
in the future.
Today, Native Client
is delivered as a NPAPI plugin.
This design is really mostly
intended for research release,
and it means that anybody who
has any NPAPI-capable browser
including Opera, Safari,
Firefox, Chrome, any of those,
can use our plugin
and explore creating
and even trying to find
security defects in the system.
The system, as you might have
noticed from my discussion,
does rely quite heavily
on x86 machine code.
It's the sort of
fundamental part
of how we make things
secure.
And the graphics support
we provide today
is pretty much limited
to raster graphics
which means, you know,
software graphics,
not hardware accelerated
BitBlt operations.
And our code development tree,
for those of you
who have sent us change lists,
is hosted internally.
It turns out that these
are basically details
for the research release,
and going forward,
we're thinking much more about
a developer-oriented system.
So some of the implications
of that
is rather than designing
the system
as an NPAPI plugin,
we want it to be built
directly into the browser.
The web worker's demo
that we're gonna be showing
is a first example of that.
But we're also going to be
preparing revisions
to the current version
of NPAPI,
things that enhance
the portability
and performance of NPAPI
as it's currently designed,
so that this will be
a better interface
for hosting safe plugins,
safer plugins and web browsers.
We also believe very strongly
that the Web should be portable,
and it is not really appropriate
to lock all future web content
that uses this kind of
acceleration
into a single instruction set.
So we're putting a lot of
effort currently into
64-bit x86 support
and also ARM support.
Now, in terms of delivering
better graphics,
we've got an effort--
a collaboration
with the O3D team
to deliver 3D graphics
and make it available
to native code.
A lot of developers have asked
about an open GL interface
and the possibility of providing
an open GL interface
in Native Client.
That's definitely a request
that we'd like to be able
to respond to
at some point.
And then finally, the other
detail I wanted to mention
is we're moving into
a public SVN repository
right alongside
the Chrome repository,
which will make it much easier
for external developers
to make contributions
directly into the system.
So...the demos
that we're gonna show you today
actually preview
some functionality
that is not in our research
release yet
but is a part of what
we're working on
to provide
in our developer release.
And the first example
is native web workers.
Now, you've heard
some discussion
in other sessions here
at Google IO about web workers,
a way of creating threads
in JavaScript.
Well, native web workers
are just like web workers
except instead of being
written in JavaScript,
they're written
in native code.
But otherwise, they have
the same execution model
and the same interfaces
as web workers.
In particular, web worker
supports no shared data.
There's no way to share data
between web workers
and the browser,
and as a consequence of that,
web workers can't actually
do direct DOM access.
Web workers support
a postMessage API
as well as XMLHTTPRequests,
to make HTTP requests
of the hosting website
and openDatabase to provide
access to stable storage.
And you can see lots of details
about the web worker
specification
at the URL
that we provided up there.
Our goals in Native Client
for native web workers
are firstly
to support web workers
and other languages
besides JavaScript,
for example, C, C++ or Ruby.
Also we still want to maintain
the simplicity
of the web worker model,
which was very deliberately
designed
to prevent the kinds
of race conditions
and other kinds of issues
that can make
threaded programming
sometimes very difficult
and provide an interface
that's basically appropriate
for low frequency applications.
Things where like
you make a request
and then, you know,
a second or so later,
you get the information back
and can use it.
So as an example of that,
David Sehr, Tech Lead
for the Native Client project
is gonna walk you through
what we've done
with web workers
for Native Client.
David Sehr: Thanks, Brad.
As Brad said, I'm gonna
be talking a little bit about
some early work we're doing on
supporting native web workers.
As you probably heard,
Matt Papakipos talked yesterday
about web workers and about
the sort of programming paradigm
that it supports.
I'm gonna show you
how we think
one possible direction
that embedding Native Client
into this sort of
programming model
would be used, so...
So here's a kind of
classic example
of an application that
you might like to thread.
It's a compute-intensive
application.
In this case,
I'm going to be showing you
computing a Mandelbrot picture.
And each one of those boxes
is eventually gonna be populated
with some colored bits.
Mandelbrot is a compute-
intensive application.
Basically you're computing
a bunch of floating point values
for each one of the points
in the region.
And we've taken this
as a little demo
and panelized it by
splitting each one of those
squares into four tiles.
Each tile will be handled
by a separate web worker.
On these modern multicore
processors,
you can have four web workers,
each having access
to one core,
and you'll be able to...
update Adobe, it appears,
at the moment.
Anyway...[laughs].
So...
So here's the JavaScript code
that does a typical web worker
sort of...application,
the one that I was
talking about before.
There's a doubly nested loop.
That's actually
just walking over the...
each of the tiles.
That's here.
And each one of the tiles
is computed
by an instance
of a web worker,
and that's created
by this just new worker.
And in the HTML 5 spec,
the worker URL is
a JavaScript, uh, script.
And then communication
is back from the web worker
by assigning this
onmessage property
to be a function
that takes an event.
And that event will,
in this case,
be the result
of the computation.
Basically, it's a big
string containing
the pixel RGB values.
And...then there's some
GU here for
putting the RGB
up on the screen.
The host JavaScript,
the JavaScript, actually,
that runs in the browser,
is able to talk to the worker
by sending--or using
these postMessage APIs.
And so in this case,
each one of the tiles
is started off.
There's an onmessage
bound for it
that will in-cue the tile
and eventually
put it up on the screen
when the last tile
is received.
And then the tile computation
is actually started by
being passed a string
that says "which tile are you"
and "how big is the tile?"
So the code, then, in the...
the worker JavaScript
has a sort of similar flavor.
There's an onmessage
that says
"when I get a message
from the host JavaScript,
what am I gonna do?"
In this case, I'm going to do
an awful lot of...
floating point stuff
and then some computing RGB
values from the floating point.
And eventually,
I'm going to put together...
a big string that contains
all the RGB pixel values.
And I'm going to do
a postMessage
to pass that screen back
to the host JavaScript
and the browser.
So...pretty straightforward,
I think.
So...our approach to this...
for native web workers
will actually use the same API.
The initial work we're doing,
just basically the text
using a different URL--
in our case,
looking for a .nexe
or native executable.
That's our name for
Native Client executables.
If you see new worker
with the worker URL being
mandel.nexe
instead of mandel.js,
well, then you will start
a Native Client
execution environment
and...run the code that was
contained in that executable.
Now, you'll be seeing this again
in Nicholas's demo
in just a second.
We have defined
in Native Client...
there's an RPC interface
which we call the simple RPC
or SRPC interface.
And SRPC methods are always
of this sort of prototype
where you basically
have a list input arguments
and a list of return values,
and so...
what we have done for this
is we bind one Native Client
RPC method to be postMessage.
And so that means
an RPC to postMessage from
the host JavaScript is called--
it will invoke this function
called Mandel worker up here.
And Mandel worker
will extract its parameters.
In this case, we're passing
strings as methods.
The web worker interface
allows you
to pass slightly richer
data types,
but I'm not talking about
that in this particular example.
So you can extract
the string value
by saying the first
input argument,
and it's a string,
so you extract that.
Then it does some computing.
This Mandel computes each one
of the point values
and produces a string.
And then when it's done
producing the string,
it will call
a postMessage API,
which is a postMessage
back to the browser
saying here's the result
of my string.
So other than the fact
that this is C,
it looks an awful lot like
the JavaScript sort of approach.
We defined an RPC handler
that does some computes,
and it eventually
does a postMessage
back to the host JavaScript.
So...the two are very similar.
So...and...
forgive me the...
posting things to the screen
is actually slower
than doing most of the computes
in these things.
So the performance delta
is not obvious,
but if the timing
is actually done,
you'll see that the native
one is quite a bit faster
than the JavaScript.
But you can see the two things
have functionally
the same behavior,
the same host JavaScript code
is used
for both the JavaScript
web worker
and the Native Client
web worker.
And we'll be developing
some more applications
to try and showcase
the power of native executables
in the setting
as the web worker support
becomes more and more mature.
It should be said that--
Brad said we're going live soon
with our SV entry.
The demo code
is in the repository.
It'll be going out.
The web worker support
will be appearing
in a Chrome release
that hasn't yet gone out.
So sometime over
the next couple of weeks,
we hope to get that out
so you'll be able to try this.
And with that,
I'll turn it back to Brad.
Chen: Thanks, David.
Okay.
So, uh...native web workers
is probably gonna be
the simplest interface,
simplest way to use
native code
and get native code performance
in your web applications.
For people
who want more interactivity,
who want to write the kind
of high frequency applications
like animation or audio
or video decoding,
we're planning revisions
to NPAPI.
We currently have NPA support
in our current system,
but to address some of
the portability
and performance issues
that we've found with that API.
Now, for those of you who are
familiar with browser plugins,
you probably recognize
that use today is quite limited.
There's a lot of well-known
security issues,
most of which
hopefully we've convinced
that we can do something about--
we've convinced you we can
do something about.
Pop-up boxes asking people
questions
that they really shouldn't
be asked in the first place...
you know, overall,
web portability
and the ubiquity of content
just kind of falls apart.
We are determined
to create a better future
for native plugins
by addressing some of
the well-known misfeatures
of NPAPI and ActiveX.
And compared to web workers,
we're going to actually
address
some of the limitations
of that system.
We will support shared data.
We will provide the kinds
of things you need
to implement high frequency
applications.
And we'll also be providing
mechanisms through NPAPI
to provide
synchronous DOM access.
So as a first example
of how these more direct
interfaces work,
I want to show you
a video player, video decoder
that we've been working on.
Now, another thing
I want to point out,
and the main point
of this example,
is just how simple it is
to take an existing
Linux application
and make it work
under Native Client.
This particular video decoder
is something
that had been balancing around
inside Google for a while.
The original test program
took an H.264 decoded video--
encoded video--
and wrote it as raw frames
into a file on disk.
It only took 20 lines
of source code changes
to take that original
test program
and turn it into a program
that's a simple Native Client
video player.
About 210 additional lines
were required
to add audio
and frame-rate control.
But for now,
I just want to focus
on the video modifications.
So I'm actually
gonna walk you through
the 20 lines of source changes
that it took
to make this thing run
in Native Client.
Firstly, in order to use
the multimedia subsystem
that Native Client provides,
and this subsystem, by the way,
leverages, you know,
the communications
substrate NPAPI
and the shared memory system
that I mentioned earlier.
You make this call
to nacl_multimedia_init
then four lines
of error checking.
And then after initializing
the multimedia system,
the next highlighted line
to nacl_video_init
initializes
the video subsystem
of the multimedia system.
Four more lines of error
checking.
We're gonna null out a pointer
so that the application
doesn't try and write
all of this video to a file
on disk.
And that's the...
initialization code.
The next change we had to make
is when the frame
becomes available,
to actually
display it on the screen.
So the original
internal representation
of frames in the system
was in YV12.
We use this call, which was
already a part of the decoder,
to create an RGB representation.
and then a nacl_video_update
takes the RGB frame
and causes it to be
blitted onto the screen.
the screen real estate
that was established
with the earlier
initialization calls.
And that's it, actually.
Those lines are all you need
to actually get the video
displaying on the screen.
Now, there's a couple of
includes that had to be fixed
and there was a shutdown
that I didn't bother including.
But that's pretty much
all it took.
So the next thing I wanted
to actually show you
is a demonstration
of the decoder.
I was actually
going to build it for you first
just so you can see
that, you know,
that building
a Native Client module
is actually not that different
from building anything else.
Surprise, surprise.
The path to the compiler
is a little bit messy.
But after that,
this is pretty much
just a normal old
invocation of GCC.
It's got a bunch of
source files
from the decoder itself,
and then starting around here,
we're pulling in some
additional source files
that implement the audio part
of the system.
And now it's built.
So the next thing I wanna do
is actually invoke it.
Now, I'm going to,
for the purposes of the demo,
invoke it the way--
typing the whole
command line out, we need to--
and I'm not gonna be running
this in the browser,
you'll notice.
I'm gonna use the debug
environment
that we use ourselves
and that we provide as a part
of our open source release.
So...let's see, staging...
There's a program called
cell loader
which is a container for running
these Native Client modules
outside the browser.
I'm gonna pass it
the debug flag,
and that's because since
we're not running in a browser,
I need to get the video file
off the file system.
And so the debug flag
is going to actually
take down the firewall
that prevents
file system access
and let us access
the file system directly.
If you run without
the debug flag,
then you wouldn't be able
to open any files
or see any of the local
file system.
Then I'll next specify
the Native Client module
which is called
G.264release.nexe.
That's what we built
up here someplace.
And lastly,
the name of the video.
And so we get to enjoy
a 47-second ad
for Google Chrome.
So a couple of things
I wanted to point out
while we're watching
the squirrel run around.
This just like
the office, by the way.
This is a portable binary.
It will run on Windows,
Mac, and Linux,
and the Native Client modules
will run in NPAPI browsers
Opera, Safari, Firefox,
and Chrome.
It's entirely portable.
We're getting pretty close
to the same performance
as the original decoder.
And...
in addition,
in Native Client,
we've gone through
a lot of effort to maintain
the kind of facilities
you need
to actually do
real-time applications
in a reasonable way,
including access
to the time stamp counter
and performance
for other system calls
that allow you to manage
time effectively.
So that's our video decoder,
and hopefully you all saw
it ran pretty much
like a normal video decoder.
That's the whole point, right?
The next demo
we want to show you
is actually an example of
the same kind of interface
being used
but running
in a web application.
So we're gonna have
most of the user interface
implemented in JavaScript,
and the fast part,
the image manipulation,
is gonna be implemented
in Native Code.
And I'd like to introduce
Nicholas Fullagar now.
He wrote this application,
and he's another one of
the lead developers
on the Native Client team.
Nicholas Fullagar:
Thanks, Brad.
Hello.
So today I'm gonna demonstrate
Native Client Darkroom.
And...let's see.
And first we'll do a little
walk-through in Chrome
and launch the application.
And note, it's just like
visiting any other web page.
If you have the Native Client
plugin installed,
there's nothing else you need.
So we're gonna open
the photo,
and it's a nice little picture.
And...so why...
why Native Client?
Why would you need
Native Client for this?
Let's say, for example,
this photo is something
that you've uploaded somewhere,
and you want your friends
to be able
to critique it for you...
and they want to make
suggestions
about, well,
maybe it looks better
if it's in black and white.
Or maybe it would look better
if you add little bit more
contrast to the image.
These are all
nondestructive edits,
so we still have
the original image
available to us.
This is nice,
because if you have it
sitting on the server,
you don't want to start
creating
multiple copies
for every edit.
You really just want
to send around
the values of the sliders
that people have suggested.
So...these sliders
are implemented in JavaScript
and HTML,
and they control most of
the GUI for this application.
This area here
is in Native Client.
And it's running
in the native C code.
And you can see
it updates pretty quickly.
We can zoom in.
We can zoom out.
We've got bitmap scaling
done in Native Client.
We've got some
geometry operations.
You can rotate the image.
And these are all occurring
fairly quickly.
And this is modeled after
some of the popular
photo editing software
that you may have
experience with.
So the other important
thing to keep in mind
is that this same web page
will work on Linux, Mac,
and Windows
as long as they have
the Native Client
plugin installed.
So...
next, we'll look at the...
source code
for a little bit.
Here's the photo HTML code
and...
Oh.
What we're gonna
look for here is...
what happens
when you update the angle.
So...
here we have
a little bit of HTML
that sets up the slider
that the user can adjust
to change the angle.
And we've added
an update function,
a JavaScript function
that gets called every time
the slider gets changed.
That calls
this JavaScript function
which passes in
the value of the slider and...
what we've done is we have
a Native Client object
which has simple
RPC calls bound to it.
And one of these calls
is Updateangle,
and we pass along
the value of the slider.
This now jumps into C code.
And as David showed earlier,
we have these SRPC methods
that we've set up, and...
we've got the name
of the JavaScript function,
of the JavaScript binding,
and it passes one argument,
which is an integer,
and it calls this C function
in our C code.
So jumping to that C function,
we've got the parameters
coming in,
and we know
the first parameter
is going to be an integer,
so we extract it here.
And we convert that
slighter value to a float
and then we pass it to
the darkroom class
and call it setangle function.
Now, it should be noted
this SRPC is happening
asynchronously
on a listening thread.
So we're gonna...
quickly just pass it over
to the darkroom class
and in its
own application thread,
when we're rendering the photo,
we'll take into account
the new angle.
Now we're gonna make
a bit of a jump,
and we're gonna go straight
into the low-level code
that does the pixel processing
when that image rotation occurs.
This is, again, in C code.
And we do the rotation
as a product of three shears.
We do two horizontal shears
and a vertical shear,
and that makes some of the
filtering a little bit easier
because we just filter
in one dimension
instead of having to filter
in two dimensions.
So this is--if you've written
low-level pixel blitting code,
this should look
pretty straightforward.
There's quite a bit
of setup code here
for calculating
what the filter value should be.
And if we go further down,
we get to the actual
pixel processing loop
that takes the image
and does the shear.
So for each pixel,
we're gonna read the source,
and if we go outside of range,
we're gonna read
the border color.
And then we're gonna apply
some SSC intrinsic code,
vector instructions,
to apply the filter that's
necessary to shear the pixels.
Then we combine the result
and store it in the destination.
So this is what's driving
the low-level...
image rotation
that we looked at earlier,
when I make this slider move
and we see the image rotate.
So this...example
will be online soon.
Keep your eye on, uh...
Google Code and, uh...
thanks for listening.
Thanks.
[applause]
Chen: Okay, so...with that...
we're pretty much
at the end here.
Our project, like I mentioned,
has been open source
since December,
and we would really
be delighted
if people had ideas for how
to move the system forward
or had an application
that they thought would benefit
from the speed of native code
in the browser.
I wanted to mention at 1:00,
which is in about 15 minutes,
there's a Fireside Chat
where some of the product
management staff
will be taking questions
about Native Client
and other client technologies.
And we'll be holding
office hours,
the Native Client team,
at 3:00,
and we'd be happy to tell you
more about these examples,
other examples
in our open source release.
Or if you've got
a piece of code
or an idea for a system
that you think
might benefit from this,
we'd be there to talk
with you about it.
So right now we've got plenty
of time for questions,
and we'll be happy to hear about
questions or ideas
about Native Client.
You guys--
can you guys join me?
man: In the mic, or--
Chen: Please, yeah.
It's being filmed.
man: You mentioned explicitly
encryption,
and you said eventually.
Could you elaborate?
Chen: Uh...
well, I guess only a little bit,
since we don't have
any specific plans.
But there's a high level notion
of, you know,
today SSL takes an entire
web page and encrypts all of it.
And there's situations
where it might be beneficial
to actually
only encrypt part of it.
But doing that over SSL
is messy.
If, on the other hand,
you had an encryption tunneled
through an HTTP request,
it would give some more
flexibility.
man: My specific problem is
encryption and signing
using X.509 certificates
under JavaScript control.
And right now,
I'm forced into using IE
with ActiveX controls.
And I would love an alternative,
if that's on the horizon.
Chen: Very interesting.
Well, the one thing that I can
promise you about Native Client
is if it's pure computation,
then we can deliver this
almost as fast as what you get
with the native CPU.
So this sounds like actually
a pretty good application.
man: Thanks.
Chen: Other questions.
Other questions
about Native Client.
man: Hi. What's the lifetime
of the web worker itself?
Like how many pages
does it remain?
If I move forward,
how long will the web worker,
the native version operate?
Chen: That's a good question,
and David might know the details
of this better than me.
The lifetime of a web worker.
Sehr: The lifetime
of the web worker is actually,
once the object
has been created,
as long as there's
a reference to it,
it's basically
a reference-counted object
in the JavaScript
execution environment
just like anything else.
So as long as there's a handle
still held to the worker,
that process is still alive.
There's some startup
and shutdown
capabilities as well,
so I can send
an explicit message
to shut down the web worker,
but--
man: If a navigator
the page forward,
and if I come back...
Sehr: We're not currently
working on
persistent web workers
that Matt talked about.
So in that case,
you'd be sort of...
you'd restart the web worker,
yes.
Chen: But there is this proposal
for a thing called
persistent web workers
which would give
a worker thread a lifetime
that's independent
of the lifetime
of any particular page.
And as that kind of progresses
in terms of
the JavaScript version
and in terms of standardization,
you should expect the native
web workers to follow.
man: Thanks.
Chen: Any other questions?
No? Okay, well, enjoy
the rest of the Google IO
and thanks very much
for listening to our talk
about Native Client.
[applause]